you're now live chair
thank you thank you tom well i'll start
the meeting
so good evening uh fellow councillors
and the wall
to uh members of the public who are
following us on youtube
so uh this is a meeting
either november an extraordinary full
council meeting so we'll start with
apologies
and then we'll do the register
or other way around i'll see you
whichever suits you doesn't matter
thank you chad i'll do the register okay
councillor belton
right no he's not thank you councillor
brenton
yeah president councillor bright
president councillor brown britain
councillor bushby russian councillor
christy
councillor christie no he's not here
kirsty
thanks councillor clark president
councillor cottle hunkin president
councillor craigie present councillor
dart
councillor ford
councillor ford
of dub president councillor hackett
president councillor hayes president
councillor harding here councillor
hawkins
yeah councillor heppel
present councillor hicks
councillor hicks
oh he is here cursey he's just trying to
immune
okay thank you councillor hudson
present that's le hurley and
councillor hutchins yeah
langford president councillor laws
president councillor leather
here councillor locke yeah
councillor mcgough yeah councilor
mckenzie
no he's not here christine thank you
chancellor manley
president councillor newton president
councillor pennington president
councillor rossi
councillor rossie
councillor watson councillor wiseman
yeah kirsty just to let you know
councillor christie's just arrived
thank you
right so uh apologies then have we got
any apologies
thank you chair and no apologies have
been received
all right thank you very much i want to
extend a warm welcome to
to uh councillor jim mckenna from
cornwall council
who's been helping us through this
process and also paul clark from the lga
is paul here tonight yes he is chair oh
good well
welcome gentlemen and um we'll see
how things proceed i'm sure you will uh
help us along the way um so we'll begin
now with the
public contributions and as far as i
know we haven't got any
that's correct yeah okay good so
declarations of interest well counselors
you know score on that and it's
printed in front of you so we're
declaring interest
should it need a rise item four uh
agreement between part one two
there isn't a part two although i have
to say under urgent matters under part
five um steve hurst would like to
give us an update vis-a-vis 1610
and that needs to go into part two so
when we get to the end of part um one
i will propose that uh that that
is pushes in part two so then six
is question submitted under rule a
nine and as far as i know we don't have
any under that
yes correct correct chair okay so now we
move into the main item of the agenda
which is
the update of the constitutions which
has been
um circulated too but before we begin
that i think
stacy is going to
have a brief introduction on this is
that correct stacey
yes yeah okay so it's all yours thank
you cher
um so it was agreed um at
the last agm in may 2019 that the
constitution would be reviewed
and as such we've had um six different
working groups
in in total starting from august 2019
and then we had a feather update one on
the 21st of october
to give members the opportunity to put
forward any suggestions for amendments
to the constitution
um in addition and we had two workshops
which we held at cadstown
as the chairs just alluded to we've been
very lucky to have the assistance of
independent
councillor um jim mckenna from cornwall
and the local government association
paul clark
and they've been um instrumental
in in guiding us through this process
the proposed amendments um put forward
um at tonight's fall council are the
ones that were agreed
by the working group that would be put
forward
i don't propose to go through each one
individually um as members will see
they're attached to the agenda on pages
six through
to pages 13. um
obviously if there's any questions or
any clarifications i'm happy to
run through those points of members and
as is councillor mckenna
and paul clark from the local government
association
right thank you for that stacey well uh
ladies and gentlemen what i propose to
do is to go through
the uh pages but i'll do it page by page
and if there's any um amendments
or opposition or whatever those
would be noted because they're all
numbered
and we will debate them at the end of
going through
the eight pages that we've got there i
mean really
as estate has pointed out we've had nine
meetings in total over a long period of
time over this
so counselors had lots of opportunity to
have input into it
plus the fact that there was a filtering
system through group leaders
and the ability to email john
suggestions as well so
there has been a lot of discussion about
it
so no more do as i say i will go through
it page by page and the first one
actually is on page six
and i will ask and we will vote on each
page
and that way we will um hopefully
get through the the agenda chair
counselor goff and councillor jones have
raised their hand
okay so we'll start with um councillor
mcgough then
councillor mcguff mr chairman thank you
much i'd like item six
um to the end there please right
six months there's number six and we'll
go for debate at the end and okay
any other any other people that want to
have an amendment or debate on
that one councillor jones and councillor
bright of race oh councillor jones
taking his hand down
councillor bright still remains because
bright
uh yeah i'd just like a bit more
information on point five of how
the climate change working group is
involved
on the q a process that's all okay well
we can answer that one now because
that's just for information so stacey
you've got some information on that
yeah yeah so so the terms of reference
are attached to the agenda sorry it's a
bit echoey is it kevin
hear me okay right yeah okay um so it's
a working group
that they will put through their
proposals and suggestions to cnr
forum yeah so that that comes up later
councillor bright
and in the and that will be written into
the constitution the
climate change working group okay but
it's a chair
um but how does that actually change the
procurement rule
that's that's why i was wondering okay
can i answer that one
certainly um chair your contract
procedurals and your financial procedure
rules
will be coming to a future meeting of
full council to
um discuss and agree um they're two
separate
documents that are contained within the
constitution so
those particular items will come
separately in a future meeting
right thank you for that so answer
councillor bright
uh yeah thank you very much thank you
right so that's the first page
sorry listen there's another one
councillor haynes now
yeah sorry church just to answer
councillor jones uh the working group is
involved with um drawing up a sort of
draft procurement
sustainable procurement policy which
will be
put forward to uh the relevant committee
or
whatever when we've done it currently
thank you
thank you for that so i'm going to vote
on this first page in
all right so you ready then you need a
proposal
thomas going to say the same as me a
proposed from the chair a seconder for
that
yeah who's that katherine watson
thank you councillor watson oh so go to
the vote on that you're ready kirsten
yes thank you chair and councillor
belton
they joined us no he hasn't kirsty
okay thanks councillor brenton or
councillor bright
councillor brown or councillor bushby
or councillor christie for
chancellor clark or councillor cottle
hunkin
for councillor craigie or
councillor dart
councillor ford joined us i'm christy
thank you councillor gupp ball
councillor hackett or councillor haims
or councillor harding or
councillor hawkins or
hurley
four okay councillor hutchins
councillor inch against
councillor james paul
councillor jones
[Music]
four councillor langford
council of laws or councillor leather
abstaining because i'm not sure what
we're voting on page six for because
we've decided
number six is going to be discussed at
the end yes that's not included in the
vote counseling letter
clears chair at the start i'll vote your
slavery in that case i'll vote in favor
then
okay thank you councillor locke four
councillor mcgoff
councillor mackenzie now he's not joined
as custom
thank you councillor manly or
councillor newton more councillor
pennington
has councillor rossi joined us no
councillor watson or councillor wiseman
oh thank you all right thank you very
much well
i should have made it clearer but i
thought i had but never mind
yes um any item which members
wish to have debated then it will be
parked and and we'll debate it at the
end
so the rest of it is we just vote on the
rest of the items on that page
not the ones that have been excluded um
the other thing is you is
worth bearing in mind of course that we
can change this constitution as the year
goes on
years go on they are although i look
older and the rest of it
i am not moses these are not set in
tablets of stone so uh
i said bear that in mind when you're
when you're thinking of your
deliberations
so now we go to page seven is there any
item on there that
a member thinks should be debated at the
end
yeah councilmember gotham counselling to
raise their hand right councilman golf
thurston
famous chairman um item number 10 please
i'd like to discuss
thank you right okay
and anyone sorry for the other person
counselor thank you chair
uh well you may be able to answer this
now actually before it goes to the
debate
um item seven the word chairman do
does that mean we have to address you as
just chair now
or and not chair mr chairman or if it's
a female
madam chairman i mean uh is this just in
the constitution or
will that be decided by the chair at the
beginning of the term
no it'll be it'll be all
referenced to the chair person or
whoever will be referred to as
the chair okay and that's
so that covers everything everybody male
female or whatever
it's just just to make it tidier that's
all
okay well we this we have we're saying
that you're just an object now then are
we
yeah well you know they can sit on them
i can live with that all right so now
oh sorry chair councillor pennington's
raised his hand
pennington yeah just number 10 again and
there is blackprint their suggested
edition
uh so that suggests we have to have a
discussion about it by very definition
at the end yes yeah we will do so i'm
just dealing with the rest of it now
so no more further amendments on that
then we'll go to the vote on that page
page seven
so i'll propose from the chair accept
them second goodbye
yeah thank you councillor watson
so thank you christy good to vote
thank you chair councillor brenton
councillor bright paul
councillor brown
councillor bushby or councillor christie
oh councillor clark
councillor cottle hunkin or councillor
craigie
or councillor dart oh
councillor gupp or councillor hackett
or councillor haines or
councillor harding councillor hawkins
or councillor heppel or
councillor hicks against
councillor hudson
councillor hurley or
councillor hutchins
councillor inch against
councillor james or
councillor jones or
councillor langford for
councillor laws or counselor leather
yeah counselor lock or
counselor mcgough yeah
that's the manly ball
councillor newton or councillor
pennington
councillor watson or councillor wiseman
oh thank you very much
thank you that's carried so now we move
page eight
so any item on page eight that needs to
be parked up
for future debate
can i just ask i don't want it
necessarily brought up we can just have
some clarification because under
membership of standards we're using
different
head of paid services um
that's already out of date isn't it it
is
can we just amend that please it is if
you look underneath
it says amend to state all elected
be removed from the paragraph
so that you carry on decision in
relation to elected members lies with
the group
leaders so the group leaders will decide
who goes on the standards
not paid officer okay thank you
right good so we'll go to the vote now
on this one kirsty i'll propose from the
chair again
yeah i'll second that thank you council
lock
councillor jones has raised his hand oh
councillor jones
thank you chair on um councillor laws's
point would it
would that not read then instead that
any non-elected members on standards
would be selected by the head of paid
service and that would be out of date
uh well i think stacy can correct me if
i'm wrong but i believe that
the non-elected ones are selected by a
group of councillors
and uh appointed that's right chair
so they're they're not they're not
included in this
chair shall i just clarify yeah the
reason for the amendment is the
constitution currently states that
the um head of paid service or now chief
executive
um it's their decision as to which
members go on committee and that's not
correct
it it that decision does lower the group
leader
non-elected members that that will lie
with the chief executive because we do
um uh interview process for that
obviously
members are often included on that panel
as well but ultimately
that decision would for the chief
executive and elected members would for
their
their their group leaders and that's
that's what that's the change
effectively councillor jones that we're
trying to achieve here
so that the chief executive isn't
responsible for putting members on each
committee clarified it for you
thank you yes it does but does that not
mean that sorry to be picky but does
that not mean that the head the phrase
head of paid service there should be
replaced by the phrase chief executive
then
uh yes could i just come in again chair
so one of the amendments on page six was
to amend all
and update all job titles so they're in
line with our current structure
so it would be amended to chief
executive uh brilliant thank you
all right okay so once again i propose
from the chair we accept these
um and the secondary did i get a
secondary i'd already second that
oh well done thank you yes all right so
we're going to vote on this one
okay thank you chair councillor brenton
here
councillor bright or
councillor brown
councillor bushby or councillor christie
councillor clark councillor cottle
hunkin
councillor craigie for councillor dart
household gub ball
councillor hackett or councillor haynes
or councillor harding or
councillor hawkins for councillor heppel
or councillor hicks
or councillor hudson
or councillor hurley or
councillor hutchings
or councillor jones
councillor langford
council of laws or councillor leather
or councillor locke
councillor mcgoff
councillor manley ball
councillor newton or
councillor pennington yeah councillor
watson
councillor wiseman oh thank you
that's unanimous chair thank you very
much
so now we go to page nine
any
updates on anybody wish to have any of
that
parked up for the end of them
councillors
sorry i'd like to move page nine please
what the whole page nine the whole of
page nine yeah
okay happy to second council hack is
here
all right so there's a poll on page nine
uh you've got councillor jones
councillor newton and councillor bush
speech here
right okay in in correct order then
councillor jones andrew jones thank you
chair um i'd like
number 15 to be pushed to the end and to
have a discussion on that
i don't know what that will mean for the
fact that we've just had it proposed
that the whole lot is moved but
we'll discuss the whole of page nine
then basically
so um we'll move on into paige um
unless somebody else got something else
to say opposing that i don't know but uh
councillor bushby's raised his hand
councillor bushby well i was item 15 i
wanted to
i was just wondering why uh that whole
paragraph is going to be replaced
but obviously there's nothing good but
it's going to be removed without
anything
to replace it okay
yes yes sorry that's there's three items
on this page why are you saying that
we're going to not you know well we must
complete the two
councillor leather proposed that all
three items be debated at the end
oh sorry all right
well that's what happened so there's no
point in staying there
chairs but i moved to accept page nine
oh bigger pardon councillor because
um people have mentioned 15 now 15
refers to the implications
plans committee used to have we've not
been working with that for a long time
now but it's still in the constitution
and it needs removing for that reason
this was
this was where a planning application if
it went against officer recommendation
right used to be brought back to the
next plans committee and it was awful
it would not work with that for a while
now chair okay well thank you councillor
i didn't realize that you were proposing
to accept the whole lot i thought you
weren't a lot removed
uh put to the back for a debate but in
the meantime
there are councillors who wish some of
that to be debated is that correct
oh no no no
who is uh chad also been seconded as
well
that's right all right
so there's no there's no move to have
either yes please sorry i've had my hand
up but
yes please i still wish to debate 15 at
the end please
uh and councillor jones councillor
newcastle jones
so that's item 15 and so the other two
items can go forward
for a vote now
sorry okay the proposal was to move the
entire page and the
entire page was seconded right
okay so it was all right so it's uh it's
been proposed a second
to accept that entire page and without
without any debate on uh
item 15.
chad please sorry councillor newton yes
sorry sorry chad we you didn't give the
opportunity for people to
um say whether they wanted to debate
anything first before you accepted a
proposal to
move the whole page so that runs against
the procedure you started the whole
the whole meeting i accept what you're
saying councillor newton
and in fact item 15 will go to the end
all right thank you thank you beginning
we'll just take
16 and 17 which seemingly are not
contentious at this point so
we'll take a vote on that page
all right 15 16 and 17.
thank you chair councillor brenton
councillor bright
caster brown or
councillor bushby or that's the christie
councillor clark or councillor cottle
hankin
councillor craigie orr
councillor dart four
councillor gub ball
councillor hackett or councillor haines
or councillor harding or
councillor hawkins or councillor heppell
[Music]
councillor hicks or
hudson
councillor jones or councillor langford
or councillor laws or
councillor leather or
councillor locke councillor mcgoff
hustler manly ball councillor newton
for councillor pennington or
leslie watson or councillor wiseman
or thank you okay can i just let you
know that counselor
mackenzie's just arrived okay thank you
right so now we move to page 10
any of those three items there which any
member wishes to be
debated councilman
councilman golf races happened personal
golf
famous chair item 18 please look at the
end
18 18 please right
okay so once again propose from the
chair we move these
and the secondary for that please
yeah thank you councillor watson
so kirsty
thank you chair councillor brenton here
councillor bright four
councillor brown councillor bushby
or councillor christie
councillor clark councillor cottle
hankin
councillor craigie or councillor dart
paul councillor gov or
councillor hackett or councillor haynes
or councillor harding or
councillor hawkins or councillor heppel
or councillor hicks or
councillor hudson or councillor harley
or councillor hutchins
councillor inch against
councillor james or
councillor jones or
councillor langford four councillor laws
or councillor leather or
councillor lock locke councillor mcguff
councillor mckenzie
uh four thank you counselor manly
or councillor newton or
chancellor pennington councillor watson
or councillor wiseman
thank you very much so now we go on to
page 11. we're halfway through
which uh it's temp eight isn't it just
um
so page 11 then there's some there's a
whole list of them down there
so councillor mcgoff and councillor
jones all right
councillor mcgoff
famous chair item number 28 piece to
go to the end 28 right
um council agencies
i can work uh item number 25 to go to
the end please
25
25 councillor carl hunkins just raised
their hand
right i thought i thought you would
right
number 27 vista 27 right
right so um that's all that needs to
move my just several there is no three
of them
um so i move from the chair again and we
accept these
so secondary for that please one second
now thank you council lock
so go to the vote then please kirsty
you chair cat brenton four
councillor bright paul councillor brown
laura that's the bush bee or
has to christy oh councillor clark
councillor cottle hankin councillor
craigie
or councillor dart or
councillor gov paul
councillor hackett or chancellor haynes
or councillor harding or
councillor hawkins or councillor heppell
four councillor hicks
[Music]
against councillor james
or councillor jones paul
councillor langford four councillor laws
or councillor leather or
councillor locke councillor mcguff
four councillor mckenzie
four councillor manly paul
councillor newton or councillor
pennington councillor watson
councillor wiseman
thank you chair that's 32 4 and one
against
thank you kirsty so page 12
items on page 12 that let us wish
to have debated
right anymore no that's everything
changed
thank you well once again proposed from
the chair we accept these
secretary please that's the hackett
thank you councillor hackett move to the
vote please kirsty
thank you chair councillor brenton
councillor bright
councillor brown laura councillor bushby
or councillor christie
councillor clark councillor cottle
hunkin
or councillor craigie or
councillor dart or
councillor gupp or councillor hackett
councillor haines or councillor harding
or councillor hawkins or
councillor heppel or councillor hicks
or councillor hudson
councillor hurley or councillor
hutchings
councillor inch against councillor james
for councillor jones
four councillor langford four
councillor laws or hustler leather
counselor leather
canceler lock councillor mcguff
councillor mckenzie uh four
councillor manly oh
newton councillor pennington
councillor watson and councillor wiseman
[Music]
thank you that's 31 4 and 1 against
chair
thank you so now we move on the final
page and page 13
three items on there any one of those to
go
no i move from the chair let me accept
these so uh a secondary please
phil pennington thank you councillor
pennington so once again kirsty
thank you chair councillor brenton
councillor bright or councillor brown
laura councillor bushby or
councillor christie councillor clark
or councillor cottle hankin or
councillor craigie or councillor dart
or councillor club
councillor hackett or councillor haines
or councillor harding or
councillor hawkins or
councillor heppel or councillor hicks
or councillor hudson or
james or councillor jones
or councillor langford four
council of laws four
councillor leather or councillor lock
four councillor mcgoff
mckenzie councillor manly
councillor manly four
thank you councillor newton four
councillor pennington or councillor
watson
or councillor wiseman
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you very much kirsty
so right uh fellow councillors that's
the easy bit done and now we go back to
item six which uh councilman goff wish
to have debated
so the procedure really now is to either
propose to remove it or uh put up an
amendment
so council mcguff what to what's your
proposition
thank you mr chairman um at the moment
it says this i think this ties in with
the number 28 as well on page 11.
if you read if you read that coincides
with that mr chairman there's
no notice of motion to be resubmitted
within six months
uh my reason for my reason for having
this removed mr chairman
would be obviously the uncertain times
that we live in at the moment
we don't want to tie the hands of the
council and not to be able to revisit
anything on the agenda
given um obviously your your item is
going to go into part two
latter part of the meeting uh you know
we're gonna tie our hands
i'd like to see this removed completely
at six months
i don't find it very helpful at all i'll
second that
that's second it okay so anybody wishes
to speak on this
yeah you've got councillor jones and
councillor christie right councillor
jones
thank you chair no i completely agree
with councillor mcgoff on this
i don't think that in the current
situation where everything's changing
day by day
and we don't know what we're going the
situation will be in the next six months
time
if we make a decision now things may
change in that intervening period and we
may want to revisit that
in light of those later circumstances so
i would hate to see us tie our hands
and prevent that from happening i also
think as well
having a six month rule is only going to
lead to more uncertainty
um as at what point is something the
same
motion and what point is it is it
different has it got to and who gets to
make that decision
um and as we found out with the with the
car parking
um situation which was in the end
we we devoted to give our our residents
the
buy one get one free approach if the
six-month rule had been in place would
it have been that we'd have been able to
actually do that for them
or would we have um hamstrung ourselves
um by a rule which we put in to prevent
it coming back
so no i i think this is um this has got
to go and we've got to carry on as we
are thank you
thank you uh for clarification stacy
could i ask you
that if we had a six-month rule
would it would it be possible if
somebody put forward the same notice of
motion at the next council meeting
to include in it to say it would require
the suspension of standing orders in
order to do that
would that be acceptable
um thank you chair um no it wouldn't um
it would preclude
the same matter coming again um to the
next council
um but if it helps chair um the
recommendation within the report
um is remembers to consider whether it
should go in or not because i know the
comments at the working group
were very divided and the working group
couldn't agree whether that rule should
uh come forward or not so we had a real
difference of opinion
and that's why it's here for full
council tonight
i don't know if it may be helpful um
chair if if counselor mckenna
um says um how they deal with
these types of matters within cornwall
if members are
minded yeah councillor mckenna would you
uh care to
have some input
german happily uh good evening again um
in terms of what happens at cornwall um
to reconsider something
uh within six months um would be unusual
unless it applies to something in
relation to a decision from
cabinets or committee and for such a
notice of motion to be reconsidered the
same issue to be reconsidered i a
decision
to be reconsidered it requires a third
of the council to sign up
normally it's six people but for
something like this it's a third of
council
um to demonstrate the significance of
the issue
so in effect it isn't usual unless it
relates to
a decision of cabinet or committee and
if that is the case it requires a third
and i can provide after the meeting the
precise wording from the council's
constitution
all right thank you for that
who was it councillor christie was the
next speaker
thank you mr chairman um yeah so i can
remember where
um certainly if we ever had the
six-month rule
uh we would have got into serious
problems and the privatization of
the pannier market in biddeford that
came back several times the trees on the
key it was almost like a yo-yo that one
kept coming back and it was important it
did
because new information came out and uh
you you couldn't wait six months in
order to change your mind
and i know that counselor mcgoff and
council bushby would have had an email
i've had today
asking about the car parking here in
biddeford
uh making an excellent point actually
about
the second covid lockdown
where so-called essential shops have
stayed open and the non-essential
ones are losing out yet again and
they're asking for us
could we revisit that parking and
perhaps do it free
up until christmas which i don't
actually have a problem with but
um so there are times where we do need
to revisit
recent decisions and i i i would support
this uh
being removed as well thank you okay
thank you for that is it counselor
newton do you
have your hand raised
i did and then i wavered i i'm cautious
chad because
this at the moment we have the ability
for the
the disaffected individual counselor
to keep coming back and back and back
because
they refuse to accept the decision of
the majority
um hypothetically i'm not pointing a
finger at any individual
and that that does need to be surely
some restraint i'm not asking for
whether it's absolutely hard and fast
but our visitor from cornwall
um uh gave an example where there was a
higher bar
a threshold to to to get through if you
wanted to come back for a second bite
it required more people to sign up for
it for instance
and whether there should be just some
some restraint so that we actually ca
do make sure that if it comes back for a
second time then
it's of really worthy and serious
uh reason that that's my my my
unease with this one that that's all
thank you jeff
thank you um councillor haynes
yes sorry thank you chuck i'm gonna just
clarify um
would it if this is um implemented would
it need a
percentage of councillors to vote to do
so i'm not quite clear
i mean this is what happens at other
councils or
is it that the as council newton says
that the bar
would be set higher um well it's not
it's not written in there i mean really
basically it's saying that if you put in
a notice of motion
uh one meeting you you could things
don't go the way
you could resubmit it that's that's what
it's saying well i think
i mean a lot of councils do have this
sort of restraint system where and
you know it's dependent on a number of
counselors agreeing to it coming back
that's not what that is not written in
here at the moment so
i think it should be well
in that case the only thing we could do
is is to actually defer that if that's
what you're proposing
we've already got we've already got a
proposal and secondary to actually
um delete it okay jim mckenna would like
to come back i believe
uh jim yeah
thank you looking at um the the cornwall
constitution again it's split into two
in relation to
motions the first of one is in relation
to a motion to rescind
the previous decision um for that to be
considered within six months that needs
to be signed again by one third of the
council's
members in cornwall we have 123
that's going down to 87 pleasingly in
may but at the moment we have 123 so 41
councillors must sign that
and that requires evidence of material
change in the circumstances
or information that materially affects
the original decision taken
and that decision is arbitrated on by
chief executive
and the head of democratic services if
the need arises
the second element which was what i
talked about originally is in relation
to
emotion which is similar to one which is
previously rejected
and again that's not permitted within
six months um unless one-third of
members
signed so the same one-third of members
and that can only apply to motions
that relates to cabinet or committee
again i can give your monitoring officer
the the full information after the
meeting should you require it
so hopefully that provides some
clarification but in both those cases
within six months
it requires a third of membership to
sign up to say yes we'd like that to be
reconsidered
right thank you thank you thank you
right that leaves us still with the
proposed and secular on the um
on the table they have no um other
amendments as such i think
you've got some more speakers sorry uh
councillor laws
chair my feeling is that if
this goes through and i've been on i've
seen this six-month rule in action
this council would be the poorer for it
there are times when it you get
a counselor with some passion who goes
on and on
banging his head against the brick wall
but finally we get there
and westwood hope park is the absolute
proof of this
uh um there may be people who still
disagree
but it was it was something that
had to be fought for and you can't this
is a gag
that's what it is and i don't like being
gagged
um there are enough rules already we
don't need this one
thank you right
so i'm sorry you've got four hands
raised now
oh well i was proposing to move to the
vote really but if you got more it was
going to uh
uh councilman goff is next
how's your mcgolf thank you very much
chair um
obviously reiterate what kansas laws
said obviously at that time
that community resource i fought really
hard there to keep that park
actually for the residents of the area
which you know
such a vital asset for them to keep and
that just
shows how being tenacious actually get
what you need to get
to represent your public which actually
work for everybody um
the reason why i like it and moved and
removed obviously the main reason for me
is if an officer is working on a
a topic then as such and the officer
decides to leave the authority
or becomes ill which unfortunately had a
few instances within taurus i'm not
going to go through them obviously
um therefore you're a stumbling block
and
that isn't helpful then for the public
you're trying to represent so
i just i just feel like council law said
it is tying your hands
and i'd like to see it removed so thank
you chairman speak little extra thank
you
councillor jones is next right well look
listen we've got a lot of people queuing
up here unless you're
uh against um having it uh removed then
um
you know we're gonna be repeating
ourselves aren't we councillor jones
well mike i just had a question really
chair with
number six it doesn't make um
the distinction between notice of
motions as we have at number
which is described at 28 and um
things which we would discuss as a
council and then may need to defer and
have
come back again so i think when i
watched back the constitutional working
group
um meeting that was one of the things
there that there needed to be a
distinction drawn
so actually i would propose that we um
just get rid of
number six and number 28 at the same
time whereas i think
the previous proposal was just to get
rid of number six
i look for a seconder well we've already
got
a proposal on the table at the moment
and i think we'll leave that one
mr chairman so just a point of order um
i did actually state that in the
beginning i said number six ties him and
number 28.
yes you did i i did say that yeah
mr bush we did it for the two
yes yeah the two you taught you tied
the two together sorry what was it 26
again
no hang on it was number 28
item 6 and item 28 on page 11. that's it
yeah okay sorry i couldn't find my page
okay fair enough thanks but two are tied
together
newton on this one really and i would
like to make a further proposal that we
defer
this particular item and ask a friend
from paul draws
up a draft um phrase for the
constitution brings it back to
the council before we make any final
decisions i'd like to see something in
writing from councillor
um
well we've got a proposal a secondary
we're taking a vote on what was proposed
the second if it falls and that your
yours could be put forward as an
amendment or
a second proposition all right thank you
right so take the vote on it um
kirsty thank you chair the vote is on
the deletion of six and 28.
thank you chair councillor brenton
abstain
councillor bright paul
councillor brown four
councillor bushby or councillor christie
councillor clark
councillor cottle hankin councillor
craigy
councillor dart against
councillor gub paul
councillor hackett oh councillor haims
or councillor harding
or councillor hawkins or
councillor heppel or councillor hicks
or councillor hudson
councillor hudson abstain
thank you councillor harley or
councillor hutchins
councillor inch against
councillor james for
councillor jones four
councillor langford four councillor laws
or councillor leather or
councillor lock against
councillor mcgoff four four
councillor mackenzie
four councillor manly
ball councillor newton
against councillor pennington
against councillor watson
council wiseman
so it's 25 four
six against and two abstentions chair
thank you let's carry chair just to let
you know that councillor belton has now
joined the meeting
oh thank you thank you very much so now
we look at item 10
which is uh key roles from members and
it's got
a heavy print at the bottom there for a
suggested edition
after communities so um i
forget who who raised this one again
i think as well right do you want to
lead on that uh well yes i mean uh i can
um
it's there in head bowl print for
discussion uh it was
quite contentious and when we had our
meetings last year i actually
challenged the role of the counselor
when you get elected you're representing
your area and uh
you come into the council you don't take
on the mantle of
of the council which is the very last
two
words in that situation um there is a
balance to be struck
um and i i wonder what the role of the
councillor is
um but i don't think we actually take on
the mantle of the council and that's my
view
and i'll just leave it at their chair
thank you uh stacy could i ask you for a
legal uh position on this please because
um
under the local government act how that
how that
squares with that yeah i mean i i accept
that
uh councillors will always um you know
have a want to represent their parishes
but when you're voted on to
torridge you are torridge district
council
and we're looking after torridge as a
whole as a whole district
and um collectively need to do that the
best for the district so
that's why the the suggestion was made
that although we
accept um that you'll want to look after
your towns and parishes
there also has to be a realization that
we are all one council
um have to act strategically um and
and um as torridge district as a whole
i mean i i think it would be helpful as
well to have council mckenna's views on
this point
um being independent from a different
council
thank you councilman please
gentlemen thank you would agree entirely
with what the monitoring officers just
said
right while you are elected of course
you represent your constituents
but you also have an obligation to the
wider torridge district council and that
must be taken into account
thank you yeah thank you yeah so i
suppose it's
really the division of the various
layers of local government you know
clearly if you're a parish or town
council
you focus totally on on your area there
but when you become
a district councillor or a county
councillor you have a bigger picture to
look at and i think that's why
that was put in however
uh proposed to have it deleted is that
right councillor pennington
i'm not making the problems in either
way i haven't i had a strong view and i
expressed that view at the
evenings i'm happy to listen to what the
council has to say
and i will interpret this determination
the way that i go forward with it
and i leave it to the council what they
want to put in their constitution
i refer myself back to the atlanta
parade many years ago
where the situation was uh our war
didn't have any representation
through various circumstances um and
there was a balance i do accept the
ambassador torridge
but it was quite a contentious issue um
because people didn't have
a voice and they needed a voice um and
you had to consider where your balance
was and when it came down to it
on a particular issue like this i had to
side with my
ward against what may have others
considered the best interest of taurus
council and that by also definition is
who decides what is the best interest of
target council
because that's where your ideas are
formed by having a discussion where
people take
opposing opposites you come to inclusion
afterwards
and accept click collect collective
responsibility
but you must be free in the early stages
to argue on behalf of your ward
yes all right well i totally agree with
that council however um
other speakers was there
newton's first and then i
raised the forward mr chairman sorry i
raised this from the affordable
beginning
as to be discussed at the end did you
why is it when we posed it to be
discussed
right okay well we'll listen to
counselor newton first and yourself all
right
hang on we'll come to you counselor
newton
thank you chair um i would suggest that
it's most important that the highlighted
text
is included in the constitution because
that
as uh stacy has um
confirmed uh reiterates our legal
position and um we had the
excellent um study day that we had at
cadstown when the
lady who i can't remember her name who
came and who
and briefed us on that the whole basis
of what we stood for as counselors
reinforced
at that point that our statutory duty
is that as a council as a whole and
the that there isn't any statutory duty
with regard to
the representation of a ward although of
course
that is there but we surely must state
the legal basis
in our constitution which is the council
as a whole
uh and i i would think that's correct
and therefore i would
be strongly suggesting that the bold
text remains thank you
are you proposing that because we
haven't got a proposal on the table yet
uh then i would propose that the the
text
included in bold using is added to
uh the the uh or the the update that uh
we're looking at there on page seven
thank you chad i would say that chair
okay okay so now it's counselor golf now
okay mr chairman i will put another
proposal in as a wording
is um to act as representatives of their
communities
within the area of torres district and
to air the views of residents
without bringing detrimental effect on
the running of the council as a whole
that's the word that i'd like to see put
in any current word in there
the rest of it struck oh we've got it
because
first of all we have the proposal as
written there
proposed and secondly that's what the
first vote will be on
okay so who else would you speak
no one else chair no right well we'll go
to the vote then
on what is printed there on
item 10 proposed by councillor newton
seconded by councillor lock
so kirsty
thank you chair councillor belton uh
four councillor brenton orr
councillor bright for
councillor brown against
councillor bushby against
councillor christie
councillor or
councillor cottle hunkin
councillor craigie or
councillor dart ball
councillor gov against
councillor hackett four
councillor haims
councillor haynes
for sorry thank you councillor harding
for councillor hawkins
against councillor heppel
for councillor hicks
against councillor hudson
or councillor hurley
or councillor hutchins against
councillor inch or councillor james
or councillor jones
against langford
four councillor laws
or councillor leather
or councillor locke
or councillor mcgoff
against councillor mackenzie
um four
councillor manly or
councillor newton for councillor
pennington
councillor watson or councillor wiseman
against
so that's 23 4 and 11 against chair
thank you very much well that's that's
carrie i would i would add
that under no way does it inhibit any
member from putting their award
first and foremost in their campaigns
for what they get involved with it
doesn't prevent that at all just follow
the nolan principles
and you go won't go far wrong okay then
so now we go to
item uh 15 on uh
the list which is uh the planning one
so which was a councillor that
would brought this one to it parking up
who was that
i believe it was me chair councillor
jones oh what
chemistry changed you're not suffering
from a short-term memory loss that's
something that's all gets followed for
suffer from
i know come on go ahead yeah i say i'm
i'm not
a um counselor who sat on planning so i
i welcome the thoughts of
those with more experience however when
i read through this i thought that it
um offered an appropriate safeguard
to the council and it's not going to
inhibit as far as i understand anyway
any decision of the plans committee
because it would only be referred back
and then the plans committee would be
able to
decide again based on the fact that it's
been sent back due to it having a risk
of judicial review
so i i personally would like to see this
safeguard
um in place however i would like to hear
from
those on planning who can give me some
more information about it thank you
thank you uh well counselor leather is
chair planning
councillor leather thank you chair well
i'm against
i'm against this with it and i think
it's separate from the
what i mentioned earlier the
implications reports that we've done
away with
this is specifically where there's a
risk of a successful challenge
at judicial review but i would rather
this was done
in public forum at the plans committee
if the plans committee reminded to
approve an application which obviously
would have been recommended for refusal
by officers i would much prefer that the
officers state in open forum
that there is a risk a serious risk of
judicial review
if they persist in in with their
approval
i'm a great stickler for everything
being done in public at plans committee
it's the most public facing committee
that we've got on the council
and for that reason we've got on the
agenda parts one and two we never have a
part
two and i would love ever to have to go
into part two with anything
we've got the public there normally and
when we're on
virtual meetings there the public do
watch on youtube
but i would rather this was done in by
the planning offices and the
we always have stacy there as solicitor
that if there was really a serious risk
that the co the committee were going to
issue an approval
and there was a serious risk of it going
to judicial review which
is a very rare occurrence but that's
that's when the solicitors sat there
along with the head of the planning
would say to the committee with the
public able to hear
the reasons they think it stands a
serious risk of going to judicial review
i would much rather that was done in
public chair so your
your support uh you're not supporting
this i propose it we do remove it chair
for that reason
right okay so the next one is um
councillor christie
thank you yes i'm just going to agree
with councillor leather because this all
comes about from um
a very contentious planning application
we had not that long ago
where um we voted one way and then
we adjourned the meeting all the public
left
the solicitor had a word the republic
were let back in and we re-voted and the
decision was changed and that was
completely wrong
it should never have happened that way
it has to be out in the open
and there is one element of this though
that does slightly worry me
um there is an item in the constitution
that says that
if it's a very contentious planning
application
the head of planning can bring it to the
planning committee
of his own back it doesn't have to be
called in by any of the councillors
we have a very contentious planning
application coming up
uh which i did ask the head of planning
would it be
brought to us and they said well no it
had to be called in
and i think we need to revisit that
because uh
if you don't call it in for whatever
reason you might be ill you might be
away
um they do tend to slip in and one has
done that not that long ago
and i think that might need to be
revisited it's not on the constitution
tonight but it is one aspect of the
planning committee that i think
but i will if not all right okay
yes i have a second without you yeah you
did indeed thank you yeah
sorry about it uh stacy did you wish to
speak
thank you chair um i actually put this
on
the agenda to be taken out because um i
i
too actually disagree with it just come
back on councillor jones's point
it's not for the the senior solicitor or
the chief executive to refer it back to
plans committee and i actually think it
causes us more problems because we're
highlighting
um to the public that we believe we're
at risk of being judicially reviewed
so we're already put in the public on
notice and that as councilor levers
stated
and there are mechanisms to deal with
this within plans committee so i
i felt that it should be removed from
the constitution
okay so uh now we've got
um my mum who we got here now who's
who's next tom please chancellor haynes
church yeah i agree with um
council christian councillor leather i
just wanted clarification this is just
referred to judicial review or is there
a provision
also relating to going to appeal
and that an officer comes back to the
committee
says it's likely that
an appeal would go against the council
is that
is is that in the constitution and not
being included in this i'm not sure
lacie can you answer that that's done
with via the plans committee
mechanism and um officers will always
give
advice within plans committee um
it is a very difficult balancing
exercise and of course
you know members are entitled to go
against officer recommendations
um it's just always made very clear that
if they're going to go against the
officer recommendation at committee
then they give planning reasons to do so
um
so again i think with appeals of
judicial reviews with with any sort of
risk
there's always a risk that will be
judiciously reviewed in relation to any
outcome um but i think by anyone
absolutely highlighting
that um that that that's that's a
difficulty
it is for members to to make the
decision and go against recommendations
should they wish to do so
right okay so i'm going to go to the
vote now um
it's been proposed and seconded so
kirsty if you do the
voting please thank you chair councillor
belton
uh four councillor brenton board
councillor bright abstain
councillor brown or councillor bushby
or councillor christie
councillor clark
paul councillor cottle hunkin
for councillor craigie or
councillor dart or councillor gub
or councillor hackett
or councillor haynes or
councillor harding or councillor hawkins
or councillor heppel or
councillor hicks or councillor hudson
or councillor harley or
councillor hutchins
for councillor inch or
councillor james or councillor jones
or councillor langford four
councillor laws or councillor leather
or councillor lock or
councillor mcgoff russia abstain
councillor mackenzie
four councillor manly
councillor newton or
councillor pennington
thank you that's 32 4 and 2 abstentions
chair
thank you very much good so now we move
on to
item 18 which is to do with licensing
is it you councillor mclaughlin brought
this up yes mr chairman it was
um can i just say go straight to stacy
please um just for clarity
um the traveller sites the transit and
the permanent site we don't have within
torres at the moment
i thought that's a legal requirement
that we needed one and i
i assumed actually going to be added to
licensing could stacey please clarify it
for me
yeah thank you councilman that that is
one of the licensing
um functions of under the licensing
committee
um so these amendments are have been put
forward by the
lead licensing officer just to keep us
up to date
on current legislation within that
committee's responsibility
um traveler sites aren't within the
licensing committee's function
so just to clarify council mcgrath this
is specifically
terms of referencing for the licensing
committee and and no other aspect
it's just to bring it up to date can i
just come back to a piece
sorry can i just come back to that piece
yeah
stacy okay that's fine stacey but where
does it fall under there
please it would be full council cnr for
those sorts of decisions councillor
mcgoff because it's budget and land of
property
if a site was to come forward okay
thank you much stacy thank you did i
could i just say
stacy it should there not be a a a comma
between um
where it says welfare halfway down it's
got uh
sex establishments caravan sites i think
councilwise we might be very upset with
that
i do not think there should be a comma
between those two
categories i agree it's just how it's
been squeezed into the books but
it won't look like that under the terms
of reference within the constitution i
promise you right
just i just just worry about cancer
wiseman that's all
never mind oh we go so we're gonna
that's uh
uh proposed for approval now our
proposed from the chair we approve that
is that right
you're saying it thank you council
watson so go to the vote again um
kirsty
thank you chair councillor belton uh for
councillor brenton or councillor bright
or councillor brown hello
councillor bushby or councillor christie
councillor clark councillor cottle
hunkin
oh councillor craigie
four councillor dart ball
councillor gup ball councillor hackett
or councillor haynes or
councillor harding or councillor hawkins
or councillor heppel or
councillor hicks or councillor hudson
paul councillor hurley or
councillor hutchins councillor inch
or councillor james or
councillor jones or councillor langford
counselor laws or counselor leather
or counselor lock or
counselor mcgoff
councilman kenzie four
councillor manley or councillor newton
or councillor pennington
or councillor watson or
councillor wiseman
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you very much
counselors so now we go to item 25
[Music]
who was uh who brought this one up
please i should have wrote down didn't
that was me again chair councillor jones
okay
i um yeah i agree with
this amendment but i just wonder why
we've limited it
to members of the committee could it not
be that any counsellor in attendance
can challenge a member for having a
interest i think that would make more
sense i don't know how that would
interact with
the rights of members to speak at
meetings that they're not
part of the committee of but um i would
like to see it that any man
any elected member can challenge any
elected member whether or not they're on
that committee
thank you that's a proposed amendment to
what's there
um do we have a second order for that
oh second nature council perspective
councillor bushby so that's
proposing second into that there's a uh
well it's a
an addendum really that uh plus uh any
other counsellor
or words to that effect that's right
i'll take your point counselor jones um
anybody's wish to speak on this
uh yes chair cancel the leather that's
the letter
yes thanks chen i don't agree with that
at all i don't
because declarations of interest all
counsellors know and it's made clear
in every committee agenda
that you have to declare an interest
usually when you get to the item on the
agenda so
mem all members are well aware of the
protocol
that exists and it's not up to other
members of the committee to question
whether a member does declare an
interest or not
so i think we should delete any other
member of the committee or any other
counselor has just been suggested
but leave it that the chair of the
appropriate of the
the actual appropriate chair of that
committee just
reminds them that they may have an
interest and then it's up to them
whether they declare it or not
but i don't want the councillors
starting to question
whether a council has got the right to
declare an interest or not or should be
declaring interest
right okay well if the if councillor
joe's uh amendment
or addendum falls then uh we will go to
yours
so because there's a director of
negative so
chairman you've got councillor lock as
well raised to hand
yeah i was just going to agree with them
leather on this
at the end of the day it's up to the
individual counselor
as to decide whether he wants to declare
an interest or not so i don't see why
that should go in
all right okay any other speakers yeah
chair could we have an opinion from
stacy please
uh yes sir on the point of order
encounters stacy could you uh
adjudicate on that one i i
i agree it's always for individual
members to
um declare their own interests and then
it
at the moment the constitution says the
chair can challenge
if they say wish so the working group
suggested
um that other members can challenge but
that's the exact advice
advice that i always give um interests
are down to the individual members to
declare
thank you scenario to stacy namely that
if a member uh could
say to the chair should you not say the
cancer
and so that they should declare an
interest so it could be done that way is
that right
yeah yeah i mean any member is open to
any member to do that anyway it doesn't
necessarily have to be within the
constitution
um but my advice is always the same
you know members are know the protocol
and are to declare their own individual
interests and i it's always a difficult
one
um for anybody else to know if an if
another member has
has an interest in the matter and that's
why it specifically is down to them
um yeah right
check i come back on that yes thank you
if we are now as we've just said
collectively all the council surely then
we all have a
stake in the in the image and how the
council comes across so should be able
to
challenge to make sure that interests
are declared because
by us being all the same council that
would then have an impact on all the
other members
yeah thank you we'll take it right so um
who who's next um councillor christie
chair
christie thank you yeah i agree with
councillor jones on this because
um if we don't accept this we're
actually
uh lessening our own rights because
uh at the last full council meeting
members may recall
that a member of the public actually
accused one of the councillors of having
an interest
now that was up to the councillor to
answer that and they did
but if councillors can't do that but
members of the public can that would
seem slightly odd to me
all right thank you councillor hackett
thank you chair um we do actually have a
check in the balance and as much as we
have a standards committee and if a
member of the council
wish to make a complaint about a
councillor who hadn't declared an
interest
surely that is the way to go forward
right cancer h is next i think well
thank you i
i was just going to say the same as
counselor hackett we have those
processes we have that policy in
force now where an individual can go to
the standards board and then complain
about another counsellor
so you know and also in committee
like you say chair we can always say to
the chair a committee member can say the
chair
you know can you ask the counselor if he
has a
if he has an interest and it's always up
to the
individual counselor whether he has an
interest or not
it's not for us to know every other
counselor's
individual business at all so i i mean
i agree with stacy and we we ought to
leave it like that i think
thank you councillor newton
thank you firstly i'd say
as just raised by councillors hack it an
inch the only problem with that
is that that is post the event um and
it may well be you may be picked up for
it later
but it won't have any bearing on the
decision being taken at the time because
the standards committee is a
retrospective affair
i would suggest uh which may need to be
a different motion altogether but
actually it's reworded to say a member
who has not declared an interest can be
challenged through the appropriate chair
full stop and by saying that first of
all it's going through the chair
so there is still control but secondly
by putting a full stop
anybody can challenge it through the
chair so we're not actually saying it's
a committee member or
open members but as stacy rather said
earlier
that um if if it was uh if it went
through the appropriate chair so the
chair does stay
have some control over the matter um
that's all i'd say
okay thank you councillor pennington
yeah thank you chair um i go back to an
incident that happened under the
previous administration pre-2009
on a part two issue and i did challenge
another member and the member then left
the room
um if you go to the standards company
route
um we wouldn't have got the information
then from the head of paid service that
we would have had had that member stayed
in the room
so we would have been we would have been
failing as our council
to know that information so that's why i
think that was included i was a member
of the
working group for the constitution and
that's why i
argue this should be included thank you
sure next one is cancer hodgson
thank you chair obviously i've been
referred to
as the party that was
um challenged by a member of the public
and
as you all witnessed i rebutted
the challenge about myself having a
an interest in the subject for
discussion
because i felt it was really important
that
i was clear about this because we were
making decisions
and i do agree with what has been said
tonight by
not declaring an interest and taking
part in our decision-making process
and then it going to a standards
committee it is too late in the day
the decision has been reached and
uh the member has been
reprimanded apologized etc our
standards we all know and our code of
conduct
is not strong in the sanctions it can
take
so i think this is something that we
ought to follow
and i think people ought to be
challenged and i do agree that it can be
done through the chair
as i did with you i asked if i could
speak
as the chair of the meeting to actually
address that interest
so thank you thank you
right so we all oh no councillor james
is no wherever
christie councillor thank you um
many years ago i actually had to report
another counsellor who hadn't declared
an interest
but i was only told about that a week
after the decision had been taken this
was a planning
meeting and the uh planning certificate
had already been issued
there's no way of recalling it they had
the permission
um so councilman newton is quite right
that standards is retrospective it's a
bit pointless then
thank you for that right so i'm going to
go to the vote now um
so it's proposed and seconded from
counsellor
jones that it's uh any other counsellors
is added to that
um declarations of interest okay so um
kirsty please thank you chair
councillor belton for councillor brenton
four councillor bright or
councillor brown laura councillor bushby
or councillor christie
councillor clark councillor cottle
hunkin
councillor hackett
councillor hackett
oh sorry four i beg your pardon thank
you
councillor haynes or councillor harding
or councillor hawkins or
councillor heppel or councillor hicks
or councillor hudson or
councillor harley or councillor
hutchings
councillor inch or
councillor james or councillor jones
councillor langford four councillor laws
or councillor leather mischief makers
charter i'm against it
thank you councillor locke against
councillor mcgoff
councilman mckenzie four
councillor manly for councillor newton
for councillor pennington or
councillor watson
that's 31 4 and 3 against chair
thank you very much i do 27
this is um dancer coddle honking
i believe 27 you
yeah to amend or pose or whichever
yeah i think 50 words to do it sorry
i think that 50 words is too short
though i think some level of detail is
needed for officer reports to be right
and accurate
and i propose it's changed to 200 words
if there needs to be a word limit
i've never had a problem with reading
notices of motion in the past
um that's what i propose if there's a
second one
i'll second that i'll second
200 words is the amendment then and
that's been proposed and seconded
so anybody wish to speak on that
no councillor ford's first chair sorry
councillor langford's first councillor
sorry
it was just a second it i i completely
agree i think 50 words is too
short i think 200 is about right okay
okay councillor christie's next
mr christie thank you yeah i'm the one
who suggested this because
um i was getting rather worried that uh
motions were becoming mini essays i mean
in the last council we had four motions
that took up one and a half pages
and i when i raised this i believe the
gentleman from the cornwall council
um told us something which was
absolutely horrifying i don't know if he
wants to repeat it
but um yeah i'll i'll go for 200 words
if you can't
get your emotion over in a very few
words then
really i i i find difficulty because if
you have a very very long motion
it just goes all over the place and
introduces all sorts of other arguments
uh i would like us to keep to the point
but
200 words will be acceptable thank you
right
councillor mckenzie do you
wish to speak uh yeah i was just gonna
say i don't think that there should be a
word limit at all um because it just
it depends on the motion you know it
could be quite a complex matter that's
being raised and
limiting it i suppose you could argue
that you know
just to get it through debate would be
uh enough and then you could go on from
there but
some things are quite complex and and
need a lot of explaining i don't think
there should be a word count then i
propose that there isn't one
uh councillor mckenna would you did you
want to
take part damn just briefly
relating the anecdotes that in cornwall
we dream of a limit as small as 200 and
200 words
not quite often they are pages so i can
see absolutely the logic in what
counselors are saying counselor clotted
honking and others in relation to
50 being too limited so it's clearly a
matter for council but i understand the
logic in terms of raising it
from 50 to 200. thank you thank you for
that so um
is there anybody else speaking who's
coming for her
listening yeah i think thank you i think
council jones and that always stop now
we agreed 50 words last time around
because it that seemed to be enough to
me to put the debate
over we also agreed three minutes of the
proposal and three minutes for the
second day
when it uh came to debate that's the
time for me
when the full uh notice can be um
can be debated 50 words we're just
basically saying this is what i would
like to happen and
it just it just goes on and on as those
counts of christie said
sometimes you know these uh get muddled
up um
as to what the notice of motion actually
is so i would stick with the 50 words to
be fair
okay uh well anyway we've got one on the
table we've got
uh 200 words and that's what's proposed
the second how does one get to speak
here
oh councillor hicks well you you
get the little thing at the top where it
says participants
press the top bar participants got it
thank you sir
and then then the little hat okay
yeah speak please has no one learnt the
art of pricy
yeah exactly
yes well you and i have been on the
council long enough to know that yeah
there's a certain
skill in getting notice emotions uh
acknowledged isn't there
and uh uh i think being very long-winded
about it doesn't help at all but never
mind it's up to individuals to decide
that
so i'm going to go to the vote council
laws has raised his hand
cancel the laws yes i'll be i will be
brief
less than 50 words cast your model back
just
just a couple of months to counsel
mcgoff's
notice of motion about car parking
he was told by officers well you should
have put in some other
options because you've spat yourself
into
a corner he was suitably brief
he was too brief and it nearly cost him
his notice emotion so
no 200 words yeah here here
all right okay right we'll go to the
kirsty
thank you chair councillor belton
uh four councillor brenton yeah
councillor bright paul
councillor brown councillor bushby
yeah councillor christie
councillor clark councillor cottle
hunkin
councillor craigie or councillor dart
or councillor gub
councillor hackett or
councillor haines or councillor harding
or councillor hawkins or
councillor heppel or councillor hicks
against
councillor hudson paul councillor hurley
against councillor hutchins
for councillor inch
against councillor james
or councillor jones or
councillor langford
councillor laws or councillor leather
against councillor locke
councillor mcgoff
four councillor mackenzie
against councillor manley
councillor newton against
councillor pennington
councillor watson again
councillor wiseman against
so that's 24 4 and 10 against chair
thank you very much kirsty so now we
come to the
last item for debate which is uh number
32
uh public participation scheme
who who raised that one i can't recall
now who's that
who wanted that debated counselor
christy that
was it sorry
yes it was council christie okay what
are you proposing
well i i have to say that um
there seems to be no limit on this uh
we had one recently where i think we had
six letters read out they did take quite
a long time
um at plans we only have two people
speak for
two against shouldn't there be a limit
placed on the number of
uh letters that the chair reads out
because
um it just says uh the chair will read
their statement
yeah make it 50 words if we go back to
um some of the very contentious planning
applications
that we've had uh you know wind turbines
where you had 400
page agendas um does that mean the
uh the chair will read out every single
letter i think there does need to be a
limit on this
are you proposing are you proposing a
limit then either in terms of time
or the number that could be read out
well
i think it's the number because some of
them could be very long some could be
very short
um there has to be some
limit on this or else you could spend
three hours just reading out
the letters that come in right so if it
was a time limit then
as a full council we have 15 minutes
don't we
or public participation and at the last
one it's true that it did
in these circumstances we got at the
moment you know it was
at the discretion of the chair and i
take full responsibility for that
to allow those to be read and they did
over lap the 15 minutes however
um it is largely down to the chairs to
decide how much of that uh public
participation
can be permitted i mean if if there's
too many people coming forward
then they they don't get a chance to
speak in any case do they because
they're they're out of the 15 minutes
unless suspension or standing orders
so i just wondered how you how you think
that that should be worded
it's very difficult as you say it's down
to the chair but
um i think we do have to have some sort
of limit i'm not sure whether it should
be time or whether it should be number
right yeah certainly counselor newton
listening to your conversation just
just there um
the number of participants is perfectly
adequately
controlled through the chairs discretion
because
the chair can see the importance of of
of the
what's been debated and a level of
interest etc
however i would suggest that the thing
which
needs control or a limit on is actually
the length of time
that each statement takes to be read if
a member of the public turns up in
person
they're allowed to speak for three
minutes whereas if they write to the
committee
then they can be listened to for as long
as their
essay or epistle goes on for there's no
limit
surely they should be the same and
therefore
might i suggest that um the
text read by a measured speaker
it works out if somebody speaks for
three minutes at a
at a reasonable pace uh how much
text in terms of word that equates to
and that is the limit
that is then placed on um
letters from the public so that
whether you are writing to council or
whether you are appearing in person
your representation is same and equal
it's for the chair to decide how how
many
we we take and how long but i i propose
that
um we put we put a limit
on the length of time that each one it
takes to re
three minutes yes yeah that's a that is
a good suggestion
level playing field with the people who
turn up um
i would i would point out cancer news
and when i first joined the council
we did have a chair who was virtually
illiterate
he really struggled but never mind well
he didn't have we didn't have public
participate participation then at all
so a three minute limit then on a
written text
i was second now your second at cancer
lock yeah
counselor newton and propose that and
council lock second adapt
so we could go to the vote on this i
think don't we oh no we got a list of
people blimey okay councillor bushby
well i was just gonna second it but yeah
that's a fine one problem
cancer jones thank you chair i was going
to suggest
that whether um council newton will be
minded to have it such that
the three minute limit is there but any
correspondence
which is received can be circulated to
members via
via email beforehand yeah so um
everyone can still read it if we can't
get through old letter in the
in the discussion thank you yeah well
that's
you could do that now actually but
nevermind cancer um
bright is next thank you chair
uh yeah i i'd rather go for the using
the chest discretion or less i think
um because i feel that we don't really
get a lot of public participation really
considering how many residents we've got
in this area we you know
get a couple of people writing letters
here and there but how many thousands of
people are out there i want more public
participation i should be restricted
okay and sir councillor oh yeah jim
mccann
please join in
chairman thank you from memory um this
point was raised in relation to people
who had intended
to attend the meeting and ask their own
question
but for one reason other between
submitting it um and actually the date
of the meeting were unable
to do so so that generally is where the
chair
would read their statement or question i
mean it is all
the chairs discretion um in terms of
extending the meeting so for example
when cornwall had a climate change
debate
there was sufficient public interest to
extend the public questioning i think to
an hour
rather than the normal 15 minutes but
the intention of this i think was not so
much for everybody who writes a letter
to have it written out
it was those who'd indicated they had a
question or a statement they wish to
deliver
public participation but subsequently
couldn't then attend
right yeah thank you for that thanks for
that reminder of what
debate took place councillor locke
go next oh no cancer hurley no i said
bye bit thank you
councillor hurley thank you chair i
agree with the fact three minutes for a
letter to be read out but i still think
there should be a limit
to the number of letters that can be
read out 15 letters come in three
minutes at a time 45 minutes gone by
that should be a discretion of the chair
um to say what how many they're going to
actually going to look at
so i agree with the three-minute rule as
a letter um but i think
the chair should say limit it i say i'm
only going to read three four five or
whatever
and leave it at that otherwise you'd be
sitting there reading letters all night
yes now i take your point i think really
we still stick to the
15 minutes for the whole you know public
participation in person
plus letters that that will that will do
it and um
i mean if it's contentious and clearly
as we've done in the past we suspend
standing orders and extend
the public participation you know it's
sources for courses isn't it
but as a guideline as counselor newton
pointed out it
it'd be good for people to know that
basically they should uh
have a letter no more than three minutes
long in terms of reading
yeah anyhow no more there on there uh
councillor pendleton chair sorry okay oh
sorry
well very briefly just to say there's uh
electronic
exclusion now happening because where
there is poor broadband connection in
the countryside
people need to send in letters to get
them read so i think we are in
exceptional times
yes if a new normal comes back and we
stick with zoom
when we are allowed to meet again um we
do live in an area where we do have
broad
poor broadband connection right in the
meantime
keep reading those um messenger pigeons
that's the answer
mr chairman mr chairman i'd just like to
extend my thanks to council mckenna
and mr paul clark entered the rest of
the committee on the
working group there for what they've
done over the ensuing year
um yeah i think it's quite interesting
very important obviously
is one of the most important things for
our constitution of the council
right go forward but i did like what you
said you can obviously revisit any time
so just wanted to stay there and say
thank you to all involved
and for the input tonight from
councillors right okay thank you
um so go to the vote
kirsty please thank you chair councillor
belton
for councillor brenton or
councillor bright again
councillor brown laura councillor bushby
or councillor christie
councillor clark councillor cottle
hunkin
councillor craigie or councillor dart
boar councillor gub ball
councillor hackett or councillor haynes
or councillor harding or
councillor hawkins or councillor heppel
or councillor hicks or
councillor hudson or councillor hurley
or councillor hutchings
inch or councillor james
or councillor jones
for councillor langford
or councillor laws or
mackenzie against
councillor manley or
councillor newton
councillor pennington
councillor watson councillor wiseman
or that's 32-4
chair and two against
right thank you very much councillors
well that uh concludes
the the issues up for debate
sorry my mistake in appendix b
is the terms of reference for the
constitution work
no not the constitute the climate change
working group
i haven't put that as a list of
suggested amendments within the
constitution so if members are happy
with those terms of reference to include
within the constitution can we just take
a vote on that as well please
sorry which page
pages 22 and 23.
oh yes i got it yes i see that yeah
sorry okay
we need to um well i'll propose it from
the chair we
accept these terms of reference yeah the
emergency and seconded by councillor
watson that's good
job yep it's cancer haynes um shouldn't
it read
under purpose um the torridge torridge
district council
climate emergency working group instead
of torridge climate emergency working
group
okay yeah that's just yeah that should
be there
yeah torres district council climate
working group okay
all right so we'll take the vote on this
so
so kirsty again please
thank you chair councillor belton paul
councillor brenton yeah councillor
bright
or councillor brown laura
councillor bushby or councillor christie
oh councillor clark
councillor cottle hunkin
councillor craigie or councillor dart
[Applause]
thank you councillor garb poor
councillor hackett or councillor haynes
or councillor harding
or councillor hawkins or
councillor heppel or councillor hicks
or councillor hudson or
councillor hurley or councillor
hatchings
or kessler inch or
councillor james or councillor jones
or councillor langford or
councillor laws or councillor leather
or counselor lock or
councillor mcguff four councillor
mackenzie
paul councillor manly
four councillor newton for
councillor pennington councillor watson
or councillor wiseman oh
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you very much for that cancer now um
i'd like to thank councillor jim mckenna
and paul clark from the lga to uh
for their assistance in seeing us
through
this very long period of uh working
through our constitution
we do appreciate it and members will as
well when we get
used to the idea of the arrangements
that have been made so
thank you very much gentlemen and you're
always very welcome to drop in on
torridge at any time
give us a shout and i'm sure we can
provide you some hospitality which we've
failed to do because it's wretched
covered but never mind
thank you so much for your assistance
yeah chairman thank you
can i can i just be clear paul stacy and
myself are looking again at item 6 and
28.
okay i believe because the two are
linked this is in relation to the six
month rule
yeah sure so you may well if you're
unlucky see us again in the new year
just a piece of tidying up but thank you
it's been a pleasure working with you
guys um
it's much more relaxed than cornwall
council i can tell you that so all good
oh well
there you are you know you know what the
saying is up here i also do it directly
you know that's
by that mantra thank you very much thank
you very much yeah
so those kind words uh in the meantime
we
also thank those of you that are
watching on youtube but
i'm gonna propose now that we go into
part two
for an update from steve hurst these are
the um
16 10. so a secondary for that please
yes i'll second actually
thank you cassary so kirsty would go to
the vote then to go to part two
thank you chair councillor belton at
four
councillor burlington yeah councillor
bright
or councillor brown
councillor bushby or councillor christie
councillor clark councillor cottle
hankin
councillor craigie
that's the dart councillor gub
councillor hackett
four thank you councillor haynes
or councillor harding or
councillor hawkins or councillor heppel
or councillor hicks
for councillor hudson or
councillor hurley or councillor
hatchings
engaged councillor inch
poor councillor james
or councillor jones
against councillor langford
council of laws for
councillor leather or
councillor lock
councillor mcgoff i'm against
councillor mckenzie four
councillor manly paul
councillor newton four
councillor pennington or councillor
watson
councillor wiseman
[Music]
thank you so it's 31 4 and 3 against
thank you so now